look at you guys look at you sharing ear
pods
[Laughter]
you know it's real when you share ipods
right
is that the sign that has to be that has
to be one of the steps in a relationship
when you're when you're sharing ear pods
it's uh it's one of the steps in our
relationship for sure
it's a big graduation point okay
you want to take my airpods sure i'll
take you it was like our vows
i'm going to say i'm jogging over the
last i don't know how long
year plus i've talked to a lot of people
you may be the first that i've talked to
who are together
on zoo i'm talking to two people who are
in the same spot
this is incredible another first that's
awesome we love that
it's either gonna be awesome or you're
gonna be like they spoke completely over
each other
but that interview sounds terrible we've
all had a different experience
during this and you guys managed to you
know put something together with each
other but do it in a way that is just
very not
showbiz it sort of seems like you got to
do things
on a much more basic level that maybe
you wouldn't have been able to
do under any other circumstances hmm
um yes kind of in many ways like coving
i could change the dating game for
everyone i think right but also brian
and i were in a point in our lives where
it was it was it was about getting to
know the other person no one was trying
to rush into anything so i think it was
like
just the perfect coming together of all
the elements and certainly
um you know not having as a tool for me
or as many
things going on had me in town and so we
were able to get to know
each other what's really crazy is how
many um
missed opportunities we had to meet each
other yeah but
but opportunities that thank god they
didn't happen because if they had it
would have been
under the wrong circumstances right i
was i was talking to
uh the the producers of dancing with the
stars at one point
um and i would have ended up being
paired with sharna which would have been
disastrous because that's
totally against your policy oh i see how
you feel about me no
it's like yeah against my policy i don't
date any of my dads
she refuses so it's like okay well that
wouldn't have worked we had other
friends that were thinking about setting
us up and never did and
um and so i think it all just sort of
happened at the right time
kind of when it was ready for it yeah
and then so
when did you guys know obviously you
work well together as just as people but
when did you know something like this
where you could work well together
sort of professionally where you guys
could get involved in the in the same
thing like we're talking about smile
train like
were you both aligned on this was this
um something that you knew about each
other
i think we're both aligned just as
people yeah you know we have
we have the same uh the the same
concerns
in the world and the same morals and
standards and so
uh doing a campaign like this just made
sense because this is
this is something that we were we we
were both doing
uh at different times in different ways
and so
when we realized like hey we can do
these things together and become way
more effective than we were
individually then then it seemed like a
no-brainer
yeah we both agreed in the beginning
when we were getting to know we both
agree in the beginning we're going to
see this
is the downside of two people on camera
when we're getting to know each other
one of the things i loved about brian
that aligned with me
is that he wants to leave his mark on
the world like how can we use what we
have
and all of the the um fortune in
abundance that we have in what we've
done and how can we use that to help
other people with
it and so that was something that we
really bonded over and when this
opportunity came up to team up with
smile train for their new campaign it
was a no-brainer for us
we want to do something like this and we
know that together we can be really
powerful in doing that and help create
change
and brian do you find that you gravitate
now where you are in life
to organizations um initiatives
that favor kids because having kids
changes your outlook on everything
i yeah i do
uh but i i try and make a point of not
just gravitating
in that way because the world is so much
bigger and i think that i think there
are so many
amazing opportunities to help kids and
serve kids and so i like doing that but
at the same time
there's so many people worldwide that uh
that need attention
um in certain in certain aspects of life
and things that we
sort of overlook because life is busy
and messy and it's complicated and
things have people have so many things
going on
in their lives and around them and and
so just to grab
five minutes here and there and divert
their attention a little bit
uh there are so many causes and so many
things that really
take such a small amount of attention
but
really tug at your heart when you when
you learn about them
and and we really feel like this
campaign is one of those things it's
such a
it's such a it it's such a simple thing
it seems like but it affects so many
people and
and it's so easy uh our i feel like our
job with this
honestly is just to raise awareness um
there's this amazing search engine
that's been that's been created this
trueheart search engine that uh
that people can use and and they can
they can donate
um without doing more than than
searching
which is which is cool it's it's sort of
a cool new twist on things instead of
asking people especially during this
time
when when funds uh when
when funds that can be given away or
donated
are not necessarily uh available right
this is a way of donating and helping
people at a time when
it's really needed uh and and it doesn't
cost you anything to do
other than just changing your search
engine it's really easy
and you you've you've built a like
almost a new relationship with your
audience through the the podcast and
through honesty
and uh i'm wondering how that
sort of changes your perspective on your
place
in in show business do you feel like
you're more connected to people now
because of that
you're you're able to control what you
say in a way like you've never been able
to before
it's funny um i mean not funny haha but
but interesting yeah it's interesting
funny i
i had such a such a crazy year and a
half
with uh with the divorce and with
everything going on
and and then with the pandemic and
everything changing the way it did
and i really connected back to um
just honesty i i just try and live as
honest
as i can and be as honest as i can with
people and people seem to really respond
to that and i think
i really feel this year especially the
people are much more
open to um open to
following each other and holding hands
and being together and being kind and
being generous
and really listening to each other
instead of just hearing
a bunch of noise that that we've been
hearing for the past
for the past four or five years it's
nice to kind of be in this place where
it's like you know what it's
we can um we have a lot more common
ground
than than we realized that we had and uh
and i feel like people at this point are
really realizing that and they're
capitalizing on it
it's it's fantastic it's it's it's
amazing and it's
it's really been amazing for me getting
to the point in my life
that i have where i feel like you know
what
it's i can do so
much for people just in in just being
honest and just reaching out to people
and just
in just being
commanding respect instead of demanding
it it's amazing how people
want to follow the lead they just need
somebody to
give them a little guidance sometimes
and if i can do that and if we can do
that with this then fantastic
yeah uh sharna before i go i know that
you had said earlier on that your rule
was that you would never
date somebody you danced with on the
show
but but but i'm wondering i'm wondering
would you dance with somebody you're
dating
oh i see where you're going with things
um
honestly i would love to dance with bry
i don't know if that is a dancing with
the stars experience because it is so
intense you know what i mean and he also
has a lot of she wants me to dance with
her
she's constantly like hey let's let you
know let's learn some stuff
um can dance he's the thing here's the
thing
he can dance he says he can't but he can
i know she says that because she's super
she's super positive and all of that and
optimistic
but um i well you know we'll see
have you ever have okay here's what
here's what i need to know because i'm
like
oh gee oh gee uh brian austin green fan
here from way back in the day
has his dance moves evolved from my
memory of what brian is capable of
has he evolved
[Laughter]
i believe they've evolved i actually you
know what i want to do we have a
pool here it's getting warm i'm about
ready to teach him the dirty dancing
lift
that's where we need to we need to see
how these things go excuse me
that could be disastrous or wonderfully
who knows
we'll post it for sure hopefully it's
disastrous that's the best way
it's been an absolute pleasure again um
smile train and hashtag search for
smiles
um everything you guys are doing is just
incredible i'm so happy for the both of
you this was fantastic
uh maybe next time we do this hey nice
nice quarantine beard by the way
yeah thank you right yeah yeah thank you
i like that
that's what i'm saying you got to do
what you got to do also
you